Hey youtubers, it's Charlie, this is gonna be my Agents of SHIELD episode 13 video.
So there were a lot of questions raised, a
lot secret organizations teased, and new groups, so
I'll try to explain those first. Careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode yet ,so
let's start with the Inhumans first. As
they exist on the show,
they're just like that small pocket
group that the Reader has been
collecting in bringing back.
We don't know who's running the group. We also have the real SHIELD,
like those plots really neared each
other. So there's Skye's dad whose fate is going to
be decided by this mystery person that's
running the Inhumans group,
and you have Lance Hunter's fate that is
going to be decided by the mystery
person that is running the SHIELD
organization.
Just starting with the Inhumans group. So
here a couple of WTF possibilities:
it could be Skye's mom who secretly
survived her operation.
Reinhardt pretty much transplanted all of
her internal organs
into his body. Probably replaced lot of
his blood with her blood too.
But the interesting thing that they teased
as part of the Skye's plot
is that you have enhanced humans - people who are modified
by science - and then you have the Inhumans, which are kinda like mutants with the X gene,
but the X gene and Inhumans are completely different things.
This is actually good opportunity
explain the difference between mutants,
like X-Men characters, and Inhumans. So a lot people feel like Marvel
is using the Inhumans as stand-ins for
the X-Men characters just because Fox
has the rights to use the word 'mutant'.
Marvel can't use the word 'mutant'.
So Marvel's weaving the Inhumans into
their Cinematic Universe, the TV shows
and movies,
to explain mutant abilities. In the
comics the X gene
is something that evolved separately from the Inhumans lineage.
So the Inhumans descend from Kree experiments. As you can imagine though, the world's a big pace,
there's been a lot of interbreeding, so
you get people who possess the X gene who
are Inhumans, but not all people with
the X gene can survive the Terrigen Mists.
Even if you're an Inhuman and you take in
the Mists, they could do something really
terrible to you.
It can severely disfigured, and your power levels, after the fact,
are always really variable. When someone
with the X gene who already has powers
takes in the Terrigen Mist, usually what it
does, like in the case of Quiksilver,
is just take their powers to crazy uncontrollable levels.
LIke Quiksilver, instead of just being able
to go super fast, can travel through time.
So at the end of the episode when
Coulson was talking about the Index to Simmons, they're talking about
distinguishing - capital M - Mutant people
from just normally modified people. Going
back to that post credits Inhuman scene toom
that's why the Reader said 'you are not one of us' because Skye's dad used science to modify himself.
He's right out of the comics. He's uses like a Doctor Jekyll-Mister Hyde type formula
that gives him super-strength.
This whole episode was about making that
distinction: who's Mutant - who had these
innate abilities -
and who's been modified after the fact.
It's like a twenty-two some-odd
episode season, so I get why they're taking their time developing this. If this were a two
hour movie, they'd just like brush over in
a quick montage.
Now moving on to the real SHIELD. So, for those who haven't read the comics, there
are several secret organizations
inside SHIELD at various points. Because
a lot of the characters
and the plot lines that their borrowing
tie in with Secret Warriors, Secret
Invasion, Civil War,
I think the real SHIELD, as Mack describes it, is just the Secret Warriors,
Nick Fury's Secret Warriors.
So of the other big organizations
that were born out of SHIELD also
include: HAMMER, STRIKE,
which is like a co-operation with the
British government that Lance Hunter was
part of in the comics,
there's SWORD which is more like a space-based version of SHIELD,
and there's Secret Avengers. Of all those, the most likely ones are Secret Avengers
and Secret Warriors and what I think is
going to happen is I think
we'll see Secret Avengers around
Captain America: Civil War, like in the movies.
It will require several Avengers to be part of it so
because this is TV show, I don't think
they're doing Secret Avengers.
Secret warriors is like one step down
from that, they're like B-level Secret Avengers, kinda.
But in the comics those two storylines, they're like the comic book arcs,
Secret Avengers,
they're completely different, they're
completely separate. Secret Warriors is
like a comic book event the gets tied up
with HYDRA.
Like Nick Fury finds out that SHIELD has
been controlled by HYDRA for a long time
and in the wake of Secret Invasion: Dark Reign creats this
splinter group inside SHIELD to do the
work that SHIELD would normally be doing.
If you guys have Marvel Unlimited, you
can totally read Secret Warriors, it's awesome.
Daisy Johnson, the character that Skye's playing on the TV show,
is a big part of that group. Nick Fury
actually trains her to use those gauntlets,
they kinda gave her the got gauntlet during the episode,
they just help her focus her abilities. The
big group
that Secret Warriors ends up fighting
against is Leviathan,
and HYDRA Baron von Strucker. So I think that based on all the different
elements that we're working with,
including what's going on in Avengers: Age of Ultron,
I think Secret Warriors is like what this secret SHIELD is,
regardless of what they call it, I don't
know if they'll actually call it Secret Warriors
on the show, they may give it another
name.
So moving it to top five moment, starting with the funny one: Number 5: we meet
May's husband. Or ex-husband. This was a lot of fun.
Like her plot, like May's plot with her
husband, is kind of a mirror for the
Fitzsimmons plot.
If The Cavalry can open up, have fun
and be like this really awesome person
with her ex-husband,
someone you think she'd normally hate, then certainly Fitz and Simmons can reconcile.
They laughing about May really does bring
them together, so I was really happy with
those scenes.
Fitz and Simmons, one of best teams on
the show, you have to bring them back
together somehow.
You guys can let me know whether you agree but you know in this like Fitzsimmons battle
that they've been having over Skye and
her powers,
I really feel like Simmons is coming
down like the antagonist
and Fitz feels like the sympathetic one.
It's really weird light to put Simmons in
but I'm totally happy with it.
Like, there has to be conflict in the
group, so a line has to be drawn in the
sand. Like someone has to be good cop,
someone has to be bad cop.
It seems like based on the events in
this episode that their relationship was
largely healed,
not a hundred percent, especially
given what Coulson asked Simmons to do
at the end of the episode,
keep secrets from Fitz and everyone else.
Bobbi was kinda like the narrator in the episode:
'we keep secrets for a living, we're spies,
that's what we do.'
Moving on to number 4: Skye's dad starts
rounding up
people that have been modified. As he
explained it, he's been using the Index
of people that have been modified to
track people that, people that SHIELD has wronged
He wants to create a group to fight them
out in the open.
The Inhumans, the people that are
actually Inhumans, are like 'wow, nope,
put the brakes on that'.
That ties in a little bit with their comic book culture. In the comics the Inhumans are
a very xenophobic, very insular, very
private society.
Attention is the last thing they want. They do not want the eyeballs of the world on them
So the show slowly teasing that out. By the time we get to the Inhumans movie we'lll
have like several seasons of SHIELD under the belt,
so it'll make sense why we haven't met
the Royals until the movie premieres.
'Cause that's like: if we have all these super powerful people, how come they haven't manifest it before now?
Because they don't give a shit about the cares of Man, until it spills into their world,
which it's now kinda starting to. Just in terms of the actors, I think they really
wanted these people to feel like B-team so
I don't expect to see them too much more.
Drea de Matteo is a little bit more
of a celebrity guest star, so she might come back on. I wasn't a huge fan of her character though.
You can make as many like Lady Deathstrike or Wolverine jokes as you want.
And yes, the guy with the sonic ability
did, you know, did remind us a little bit of Black Bolt.
But I think that's just a little winking at the audience. Black Bolt's ability is way
more complex than just putting people to
sleep with certain sonic frequencies.
If he had screamed at that microphone, it would've been like an atom bomb going off.in the city.
It would have left like a giant crater. Onto number 3: Mack captures Lance and takes him the real SHIELD.
This was a pretty big WTF, so let's follow
the thread here:
he captures Lance, doesn't tell Coulson
about it. Lance and Mack are both outside of the base.
Eventually Coulson is gonna be like 'hey,
where did these guys go? What's going on?'
Bobbi did tell him that Lance just took
off, but Coulson isn't an idiot, so he probably
has an idea that something's going on.
I don't think that Bobbi and Mack are
evil, they're not working for an evil team,
it's not like a group of people walking
around slaughtering people. That's why I
think the show is moving towards Secret
Warriors-Nick Fury territory
just because it would develop with movies really nicely and
it would be a way to keep these characters, to keep these Bobby and Mack characters,
sympathetic while pitting them against the
team but without turning them into villains.
And Adrianne Palicki he was up to series
regular, so Mockingbird here
is going to be on the show in a big way
for the rest of the season. Really what
the show is trying to do is
position like these three different
groups, you have like this secret, like
new SHIELD,
you have proper SHIELD with Coulson, and then you have this Inhumans group
and they want all them to feel relatively
equal, like none of them are
evil organizations but one is gonna have to be the antagonist
to the other two at any given time. So like
the Inhumans
really hate bothof the SHIELD group, the
Secret SHIELD, like that new SHIELD as
Mack describes it,
is probably gonna be way more hardcore
about tracking those people down.
It'll be like a situation where the
secret SHIELD will go after the Inhumans,
and Coulson will have take his SHIELD team to get in between them.
So even though none of them are technically evil, they'll be at each other's throats by
the end of the season,
which is why I'm really waiting for like
a new villain to surface.
And the confusion will just provide a
really nice opportunity for someone
really evil to surface, like one of the heads of HYDRA,
or somebody even crazier. I do think it's
possible for Whitehall to come back and
be like the really big bad at the season.
Even though he's technically out of commission as far as we know, I really do
feel like that would be an awesome way
to close the season down where you have like
Skye's mom who actually isn't dead,
surprise surprise, and you have Whitehall
who surprise surprise isn't dead
and they just go at each other. Dichen
Lachman is a great actress I was really
happy whenever she came on Agents of SHIELD
and really bummed when they killed her off
super quick. I think her role on the show
is more complex than we know right now. Moving onto number 2:
Skye starts to figure out her powers. There were a couple minor changes from
the comic books.
So in the comics, Daisy Johnson is immune to her own abilities,
but on the TV show they explained it as
her like redirecting her tremors
inside herself, which was like shattering
all her bones. The reason they did that is just to
make us emotionally connect with Skye a
little bit more.
It's the TV show turning Skye's powers into
a metaphor
for what's going on inside her head.
That's your dime-store-Marvel-psychology
lesson of the day.
To explain the gauntlets: she has the
gauntlets in the comics
and they just help her focus her
abilities. Nick Fury gave them to her.
On the show, they were a little more practical but what they'll probably do is
evolve into the gauntlets of the comics.
What I'm really interested to see is like how
many episodes go by before Skye actually
learns to focus her abilities like,
is going to be the end of the season, or
are gonna see that in the next couple episodes?
I feel like they would hang that over
our heads for too long, like it's too
much fun watching someone use their powers
enjoying it. And finally, my number 1, WTF
moment: Skey's dad is taken back to the
Inhumans base.
We haven't seen a lot from inside that
place, we've only seen like the Reader
in flashbacks.
but based on the architecture. it seems
like it's around the same place where
Skye's mom was captured and died, like the place they lived in China.
I did think it was interesting that Skye's
dad didn't totally recognize the Reader,
but maybe Skye's mother never fully brought him onto the team. Because
if she was alive in the flashbacks, in
like, you know, totally normal, totally big part
of the society,
maybe her association with him was just
in the outside world.
Doesn't it feel like like a very cats in
the cradle thing for them to do to? To like bring
Dichen Lachman been back on the show like, 'surprise your mother isn't dead, she's
alive' and like have this big, happy moment
for Skye at the the season.
That just feels like a very TV need to do,
but you guys can let me know if you agree.
Do you think that Skye's mother
is secretly still alive on the show, or
she will surface at some point?
And do you think that Whitehall is also still alive? So I already explained most of the Easter Eggs in the
episode like, the real SHIELD-Secret-Warriors type stuff.
There was one really cool Easter Egg that
was kinda meta: the diner that they were
eating in is the Pulp Fiction diner.
I just though that was kinda funny because that's a big Sam Jackson movie
Sam Jackson, Nick Fury, Pulp Fiction. Pulp Agents of SHIELD Fiction.
If you gys did see other Easter Eggs that I didn't mention the video, just write them below
in the comments, but next week is a new
episode be sure to subscribe to my video.
I'll probably post it Wednesday morning, that's usually when I've been posting my Agents of SHIELD videos.
In case you guys haven't seen it, there was like some crazy WTF
on The Flash last night, you can click
here to catch up with that,
and you can click here for all my other
Agents of SHIELD Inhumans videos.
Thank you so much watching, I'll see you guys tonight. Let's all do the thing.